être sur scène pour exprimer ses
sentiments par la danse ou encore en
déclamant des textes c'est l'objectif du
concours slam et danses urbaines
organisé par le département de la
réunion la scène du théâtre de champ
fleuri qui a accueilli pour la septième
année consécutive les spectacles du
collégien
ils étaient plus de 200 collégiens avoir
investi la salle ou encore le plateau du
théâtre pour montrer leur talent en deux
catégories ont permis de les départager
le slam et le hip hop comment son
histoire de l'espoir les jeunes
collégiens ont pu ainsi fêter la musique
surtout s'éclater en regardant les
démonstrations de leurs camarades les
prestations de talent comme l'a souligné
la conseillère départementale jacqueline
henry fois que j'assiste à cette
manifestation pour la 7ème édition et
j'ai trouvé ça très intéressante les
enfants sont très enthousiasme et plein
de talent et je suis fier de représenter
le département aujourd'hui un site à ce
concours
une aventure artistique mais avant tout
un concours il a donc fallu départager
tous et performeurs et là la tâche du
jury a été rude
issu du monde professionnel ou encore du
conseil départemental des jeunes ces
derniers ont eu beaucoup de mal à
départager les collèges
c'est vraiment une grosse réussite par
rapport à ce qu'on attendait c'est
exactement ce qu'ont pensé les jeunes
étaient vraiment investi et
vue du slam et des danses comme comment
ce thème
les professionnels étaient été rapide je
pense que c'était vraiment une action à
reconduire donc la septième édition et
elle est très content de l'avoir fait il
s'agit de la septième édition cette
année on a changé en tout ip on a fait
tous les prestations culture le matin le
concours et matin et la délibération à
l'animation après midi et c'est vrai que
au vu de tous les impressions des
personnes qui étaient là donc c'est vrai
qu'ils ont préféré ce changement
il faut en effet souligner que c'est le
conseil départemental des jeunes avec le
soutien de la collectivité qui organise
cette manifestation
dans la catégorie slam les trois
premiers prix ont été attribués au
collège pointe des châteaux collège les
mascareignes et les collèges plateau
caillou le coup de coeur du jury qui a
été attribué au collège de la ravine des
cabris dans la catégorie danse urbaine
c'est le collège jean le toullec qui
remporte le concours le deuxième prix
est attribué au collège dimitile c'est
le collège teixeira da mota qui décroche
la troisième place